[Music]
the last time I saw you we were having
lunch where we weren't having lunch
together right yeah when I was like in
the Los Feliz area of Los Santos and we
were in the same we mean some like
superstar kind of scenario because I was
there with two axes a friend of mine
Megan Fox was behind me having lunch you
name dropper yeah well a friend of mine
was there too but they're not new you
assign a table and you very sweetly
remembered the last time that we we met
and I remember thinking wow what a
deeply powerful man because you were sat
there with your eating partner and you
had like a ton of papers that you just
very casually sign in and pass it on and
sign it remember that yeah I remembered
I was working up here was but it just
passed the papers and then what did you
think
well I when we were talking I like
looked over to see the papers that you
sign it and one of them was that you
were you were gaining like copyright
that you could only have that hairstyle
that is that true that was the paper
that I read my lawsuit with Bob's Big
Boy is still two years
no you know it's funny cuz you mention
that and I know that you seem to think
that it was my lawyer it was the head
writer here on the show we were going
over different submissions because
someone want to be right on the show but
I love that you thought I was doing
powerful just writing those words on
paper million three million sir you're
insane you have to leave and I was it
was probably just a stack of fart jokes
approve approve them all there without
farting aren't they I was I was tickled
by some of your comments about
chick-fil-a today on Twitter sorry yeah
I know the urine you're very much into
yeah I actually reached an agreement
with chick-fil-a
which is fantastic yeah they agreed to
not shove their disgusting bigotry down
my throat and I agreed to not shove
their disgusting chicken sandwiches down
people's
[Applause]
so I take it you're not a fan I just
don't want chicken we have a clip here
from the movie the day tell us a little
bit about the day the day is a movie
about a group of survivors trying to get
from one part of America to another when
it appears that you know society is
broken down and humans seem to be eating
each other
good god it's off and this is this is a
family film yeah yeah yeah let's take a
look at this clip from the day the skies
are clear we got I said he can't even
barely stand up what are we gonna leave
me here sitting ducks right now we gotta
go stop all right if you can't walk
won't matter if you stay or hey I can
manage let's go that's right do you
manage it's not at the speed that you
need to we stay the night when was the
last time we had a roof over our heads
anyway hey we have a protocol right
right and what's more important right
now Adam oh don't give me that we gotta
go I'm gonna go right now
there's no discussion we stay until
Henson is strong enough again could we
make use of her like
American accent yeah is that hard to do
I would think I've always thought it
must be hard to do an American accent
because it's kind of unnatural it's a
weird thing when I was a kid I you know
I played bugs Malone FL well I felt like
it was effortlessly and then when I
started doing it for a living I felt
kind of constrained by doing an American
accent what happened was you know when
you do accents obviously it's all about
kind of a relaxation and just being okay
with it but I was quite nervous so when
I would talk my chest would be kind of
constraint and I sound like some like
young Jewish guy when I would speak so
then I like physically tried to just
like open up my chest and then the
American accent kind of comes through a
little bit better but it's important to
me because I live in America and I love
America and I hope to work in America
for the rest of my life so it was
important for me to try and play an
American at least slightly convincingly
yeah I can continue Carmen thank you yes
no one knows the American it's not you
you wanted to I'm told you wanted to
tweet a surprise at the end of the show
is that oh well I figured like you know
after this I was gonna go to a diner
just down the street called Moe's and I
was gonna see if anyone from the
audience wanted to come and hang out no
one
absolutely no one wants to go oh no
what's that yeah let's go go yeah we're
gonna go Erica right here in Burbank
yeah yeah Riverside all right Oh Mose I
do own moans yeah very smart
it's your restaurant